Prometheus is a massive ocean liner
that's set off on a seven day long
Voyage four months ago the entire ship
and its 2 000 passengers have been
missing since then this has become a
massive scandal in Europe because the
first class passengers of the ship were
some well-known important people rumors
about what happened to the ship fly
around the entire continent but every
attempt to find the ocean liner has
failed the opening scene shows us a
woman named Maura running down the
hallways of a mental Asylum she is
running from her father cursing him for
doing something to her brother Maura
vaguely mentions a lost ship and accuses
her father of killing many people the
ship she is talking about is Prometheus
in the following scene Mora wakes up and
assumes that she was only dreaming
however the marks on her wrist that she
got in the Asylum say otherwise Maura
vaguely remembers what happened to her
but most of it is just a blur it is
almost as if someone erased the past few
months from her memory currently she is
aboard another ship on her way to
America from England this ship is also
on a seven-day journey and holds more
than a thousand passengers the people in
first class are the high class
passengers while those in the middle and
working class are either refugees
criminals or Wanderers they live in the
lowest shared compartment and are given
less to eat while the first class
passengers are served the finest
Delicacies of the world what no one
knows is that every passenger on board
has a secret they are hiding first class
is probably hiding that they're a bunch
of a-holes Mora is one of the first
class passengers and is here because she
received a letter A few days ago the
letter was from her brother in it he is
asking Maura to come to New York
asserting that he knows what their
father has done this is the very reason
Maura is aboard the ship even though she
is in bad health and mentally unstable
Maura looks into the mirror and reminds
herself what her name is so she won't
forget if someone tries talking to her
in the dining area are a recently
married couple Lucian and Laura because
the marriage was an arrangement by their
parents they don't love each other
Lucian instead has an eye for a Japanese
prostitute on board meanwhile the said
prostitute is with her mother dressed in
traditional Japan Japanese kimono but
speaking Cantonese it turns out that
they are pretending to be Japanese for a
better life abroad Maura is sitting
alone when a woman named Miss Eve sits
beside her Eve is the owner of the
prostitute and is taking her to America
to sell her to a brothel Mora gets
annoyed as Eve gets intrusive with her
questions but the two are interrupted by
the arrival of a man he is a lowly
worker from the lower class who is not
allowed to even look at the first class
passengers he asks if there is a doctor
on board because his sister is dying in
the lower compartment the man is taken
away by the guards but Mora follows them
revealing that she is a practicing
doctor and because the male doctors on
board are stuffing their fat faces with
gruel she goes to the lower compartment
and helps the pregnant woman the people
are skeptical but her little sister
trusts Maura when the woman stops
hurting Maura's expertise is proven and
she quietly comes outside this is when
she meets the captain of the ship he
lost his wife and daughters in a house
fire two years ago and is still mourning
their deaths the captain talks tomorrow
for a while before they are interrupted
by his assistance they reveal that they
have been getting a signal from
somewhere nearby that shows them the
coordinates of a place the captain has
reasons to believe the signal is coming
from the Lost ship to investigate he
disregards the passengers and turns the
ship around Mora goes to talk to the
captain and inquires if he thinks anyone
on the Lost ship might still be alive
since they were gone for four months the
captain knows it is unlikely but hopes
that they rationed out their food and
survived after moral leaves the captain
brings out an envelope similar to the
one she received from her brother this
one is from someone named Isle a while
later the captain addresses the
situation with the first class
passengers and tells them he is turning
the ship to get to the coordinates most
of them are not happy about the decision
but the captain remains adamant a few
hours later they finally reach the
coordinates and confirmed that it is
indeed the Lost ship the captain orders
his assistance to lower a Lifeboat and
chooses a group to accompany him to the
Lost ship the group consists of two
lower class men olak and Jerome Mora and
a few more people to keep watch when
they finally reach the Lost ship and
climb up they are shocked to see no one
not even a dead body is lying anywhere
and the entire ship seems to be
abandoned the captain is especially
confused about how they received the
signal because the device used to do so
is destroyed suddenly Maura notices a
beetle moving on the floor and follows
it the insect leads her to a room near a
locked cupboard Maura carefully opens it
and is shocked when a little boy comes
outside he doesn't speak or show any
emotions but he is holding a strange
pyramid questions about his survival
linger around the group before they
bring him to their boat Maura agrees to
keep him safe in a room and to take care
of him since she is a doctor that night
a man who seems to have swam over from
the Lost ship secretly boards the
Kerberos the following morning every
compass on the ship stops working people
question if they will suffer the same
fate as the passengers of the Lost ship
and even the captain doesn't know what
to do next meanwhile Mora is busy taking
care of the kid she returns to her room
with food for him and finds a stranger
standing outside her door it appears to
be the man who boarded from the Lost
ship the man quickly shifts to another
door and explains that he heard whimpers
from her room and simply wanted to check
up on her he also introduces himself as
Daniel her neighbor Maura asks the man
if they have met before because he seems
familiar but he dismisses the
conversation and walks into his room
after that Maura asks the Kid what he
was doing on the ship however the boy
remains silent and hands her the pyramid
he was found with it seems like he is
trying to communicate something with her
but she can hardly interpret it
meanwhile the captain assumes that
everything with the Lost ship has to do
with the ship company before the voyage
he received a letter from the company
that had only two words sink ship he
thinks that the company wants them to
sink the recently found ship to hide
their misdeeds his staff thinks that he
is thinking too much the captain is
asked to make up his mind about what he
wants to do now the passengers and even
his own crew are beginning to question
his authority because the ship hasn't
moved in such conditions his mental
health deteriorates and he starts
hearing the sound of his daughter
singing following the sound he he
reaches the room where his wife and
daughters died it is revealed that the
house fire that killed them was not an
accident but was set by his own wife to
kill her daughters and herself the
captain probably should have played
Django with them more often or whatever
people did back then the captain tries
talking to his family but his wife
ignores him and takes the kids away
leaving only his eldest daughter behind
the girl tells her father to come back
and the lights on fire this brings the
captain back to reality however when he
opens his eyes he finds himself inside a
compartment under his bed he is shocked
because he knows every corner of the
ship but was unaware of the compartment
right under his own bed at that moment
the captain decides that he is taking
the Lost ship to the shore no matter
what since they lack enough coal to drag
it to America they will have to return
to England somewhere else Moro finds a
tattoo on the boy's neck that is similar
to the mark on the envelope she received
she reveals to the kid that her brother
has been missing for the past four
months and she had no clue where he was
before she received the letter the Mark
is very important to her and she wants
the kid to explain what it means the boy
listens to everything and starts crying
but still doesn't say a word when Mora
leaves her neighbor Daniel comes outside
her door again this time he lets out a
beetle from his palm similar to the one
that was found on the Lost ship it turns
away from the door and walks down the
hallway a little girl from the lower
class passengers finds it follows it and
bumps into Daniel he apologizes to her
and the scene Cuts abruptly somewhere
else the captain tells the passengers
that they are going back to England and
nobody's happy about it people start to
protest but he goes against everyone and
remains adamant in his decision Maura
follows him to the deck and asks him
what is going on the captain tells her
about the sink ship message sent by the
ship's company he also assumes that he
and Moro were sent on the ship for a
reason having known about the letter she
received that was similar to his later
the dead body of the little girl is
found and a male doctor is called to
find out the cause of her death he
carelessly declares that she died of
natural causes because she was sick Mora
questions his credibility but the Man
shows her no respect the only think this
guy's got a PhD in his sexism suddenly
the captain is called outside to see the
fog they are surrounded by till now they
were using the sun to figure out the
direction they were going however with
the fog covering them the direction is
difficult to navigate the captain
returns to his room with Mora and shows
her a piece of ribbon that belonged to
his daughter he also discloses that he
found the ribbon on the Lost ship he
believes that his family was on that
ship even though they have been dead for
a long time Maura and him decide to go
back to the Lost ship once again to
check the captain's logs and find out
more about what happened there they go
to lower the Lifeboat but are stopped by
the head of security on the way he is
very unhappy with the captain's decision
to return to England and thinks his
obsession with the Lost ship will harm
them all still the captain ignores his
words and continues lowering the boat
after they leave the head of security
and the captain's second in command
decides to Rally people against him Yar
it's time for our Mutiny boys the head
of security goes to the lower class
people and tells them about the little
girl's death he pins them against the
captain and tells them to approach test
since the lower class people do not have
enough money to get a ship ticket for a
second time they don't want to return to
England a while later they find three
more dead people on the ship who seem to
have died as the little girl did this
fills them with rage and people get
ready to fight for their rights
somewhere else the captain and Maura
reached the Lost ship and go through a
room they find that every official paper
has been burnt in the fireplace but the
captain manages to get a single unburnt
piece of paper out it has the list of
passengers aboard the ship they also
come across a Strange Electric Board
attached to a wall the captain reveals
that it is a new addition to the ship
that happened last year and is used to
measure the steam pressure it suddenly
hits him that the instrument is
basically useless which means it must be
there for something else he is scared
for his passenger's life because their
ship also has the same instrument this
further proves his theory that the ship
company has something to do with the
Lost ships and the dead people to make
matters even more confusing the captain
sees that Maura's name is on the missing
ships manifest then we see the Japanese
prostitute looking over the sea the
married man Lucian approaches her and
tries to start a conversation but the
prostitute walks away to avoid him the
interaction doesn't go unnoticed by her
owner Eve she comes to leucine with a
proposal and agrees to let him spend the
night with the prostitute for a lot of
money later Eve checks The Prostitute to
ensure she is clean and finds out that
she is actually a virgin a flashback
shows us that her mother used to work in
a brothel one day the best prostitute
got an opportunity to work abroad and
get a better life the women were jealous
so they killed the said girl and took
her place on the ship the Virgin
prostitute knows that what they did was
wrong and she accepts her Fate by
agreeing to sleep with Lucian The Night
comes and Lucian lies to his wife about
wanting to sleep in another room we see
him avoiding taking his medicine because
of this he gets a seizure right before
the prostitute takes off her clothes we
find out that Lucian is taking medicine
for these seizures but if he takes it it
makes him impotent bit of a catch-22
there Upon returning back to their ship
the captain looks at the paper he found
he is shocked to see Maura's name on the
the passenger list of the Lost ship this
means that she was also on it but the
captain has no answers for how she
returned and what secrets she is hiding
in the following scene Daniel meets
Maura and asks her how she feels about
the captain Maura finds the question
strange but she says that she trusts him
with her life because he has been
through a lot and wants the best for his
passengers meanwhile the people of the
lower class start Gathering guns and
weapons determined to take over the ship
and get it to America before the captain
is warned he is surrounded by Rivals
simultaneously we see Daniel trying to
use the strange machine that the captain
saw on the other ship earlier the
captain and three of his supporters are
locked into a cabin with their hands
bound the chief security then finds out
that the compass has started working
again upon checking their location the
crew is shocked to realize that they are
in the same exact position that they
were three days ago when they initially
deviated from the course even the oldest
members of the crew have no explanation
for this because they have been moving
continuously since they were last in
this position in the meantime the
protesters surround a staff member and
ask him to tell them why their people
are dying in fear the man recounts
everything that has happened on the ship
since they received the signal from the
Ghost Ship when the group finds out this
happened after the kid was rescued they
blame the deaths on him assuming that he
brought a disease the protesters Roar in
anger and set off to look for the kid
and kill him first they go into Maura's
room but find it empty after looking
around and confirming the kid is not
there they lock Maura in and walk away
to check the other rooms as Mora grows
worried for the boy she hears a noise
from under her bed she moves it to take
a look and finds a hidden compartment
similar to the one under the captain's
bed The Boy comes out of the compartment
looking like a little demon and Mora
breathes a sigh of relief one after
another the protesters locked the
high-class passengers into their rooms
Maura tries picking her lock as the kid
watches her struggle then he brings out
a beetle and the insect magically
unlocks the door from outside Morris is
stunned but she doesn't have enough time
to dwell on the matter they run to the
Lifeboat and reunite with the captain
and his reporters it turns out that he
escaped the room they were locked in by
crawling into a vent currently the group
is planning to run away in the Lifeboat
Maura tries joining them but the captain
is skeptical after having seen her name
on the passenger list of the Ghost Ship
before the group can lower the Lifeboat
the protesters arrive and take the
little boy away to be killed it starts
raining heavily as they get ready to
sacrifice the kid and I don't blame them
he looks like the thing from The Omen
however he doesn't seem scared almost as
if he has accepted his fate seconds
before they slice his throat the captain
and his supporters come to his Aid a
fight ensues between the two parties and
many people are injured Maura does her
best to get to the kid but a woman
throws him off the ship before she can a
while later the captain's group takes
care of their injuries in the lobby Mora
is still shocked and horrified because
she had grown a connection to the little
boy during the time they had spent
together having had enough the captain
calls Maura out for playing dumb and
shows her the names on the Lost ship's
passengers list Mora is shocked because
she doesn't remember being on the ship
at all she tries to discredit the paper
but stops when the cupboard nearby makes
a noise everyone watches in shock as the
little boy comes out of the cupboard
holding the strange pyramid as he did on
the Lost ship the episode ends when he
walks up to Mora and hugs her to see
what happens next watch the second part
in series recapped